and good evening we're talking baseball
tonight the reyes day plata is hosting
the
salt lake beast now to close out a home
stand so there's some baseball out of
the ballpark come on down have some fun
beautiful weather out here a little
windy but we're loving it out here
hey the aviators uh parent club the
oakland a's
they want a new home so they've been
shopping around major league baseball
said
go ahead and look around they can't get
that waterfront park done and it looks
like they might have to move out of
oakland they may not want to but they
may be forced out because there's no
big money there we talked to some of the
fans here at the ballpark and some like
it some against it this is what they had
to say
i think a professional baseball team in
las vegas would be amazing
but i know at an expense of the aviators
i like the stadium here and
stuff like that but i think major league
baseball in vegas would be amazing
love baseball don't think las vegas
could handle a team
a major league baseball team i think we
do great with the minor league team
the aviators did a wonderful in 2019
we'll see how they do in 2021 but
i'd love to see a major league team here
but i just don't think it can be
supported
i think it's awesome i think vegas has
proved to be a great sports town
the fans are great the teams have been
great it's been very successful
so bring it on another team
all right so the a's executives say
we're going to meet with us today
they're not going to they're waiting for
their pr crew to get into town
they're probably going to talk to the
media either tomorrow or the next day
possibly on
friday